this week conflict zone is in the polish
capital warsaw where tension is running
high over a resurgent russia my guest
today is radossuav sikorsky he's a
former polish foreign minister and
former speaker of the polish parliament
he resigned recently after a major
bugging scandal in which he was heard to
make unflattering comments about
poland's relations with america what
does he really think
welcome to conflict zone hello good to
have you here you said in april 2014 we
should abandon post-modernist illusions
that conflict is unthinkable
is that conflict with russia that you
think is now
thinkable
well
the
post-communist era of the peace dividend
of rebuilding shattered economies of
reducing defense budgets
was a very good era
and
i think we were all hoping that russia
would join in that russia was on a
broad
trajectory of
convergence with the west but this is
quite a warning that war is now
thinkable war with russia is thinking
well you only need to listen to
president putin's words for example his
annexation speech of crimea and you only
need to analyze
russia's defense budgets and you only
need to
follow russia's actions whether in
georgia or in crimea or in
donbass
and you have to conclude that russia is
a revisionist power that is not happy
with its place in the world in europe
it's not happy it wants to expand its
borders and it's willing unlike us to
use force to uh to affect change well
you say unlike us because that's
absolutely true isn't it america germany
and britain have all made clear they're
not going to use violence
well it's not
especially especially where ukraine is
concerned what did chancellor merkel say
there's no military solution to ukraine
let's come to that but i meant it in a
more general sense in that
we learned as a as an outcome of um
two world wars that
all borders in europe are artificial and
that
um changing them by force on the pretext
of um
protecting your compatriots is a road to
disaster and and and and russia is
revisiting that terrible european 20th
century
past but the problem is as you alluded
to they are high risk takers and the
rest of europe are low risk takers
that's exactly right so they have the
advantage
in in a sense yes they will go further
they will do more they will expand and
you have to give it to the russians they
have a more
imaginative
um
defense
doctrine
uh
you know using hybrid methods using
low intensity conflict
using deniability little green men this
is something that democracies are
incapable of doing but you want more
nato troops in poland you said nato
grossly neglected its eastern front well
nature needs to be serious about defence
because only then can it
fulfill its
it's function which is to first of all
to protect the territory of its members
so nature which is is committed to do
yeah
and the nato uh
nato
mission has to be credible well what's
the point of saber rattling what's the
point of waving your weapons in their
face so that they wave more of theirs
we shouldn't say
and we spent 25 years
trying to persuade russia to to join the
world of rules
uh billions was was spent uh helping
russia overcome its economic
difficulties
uh
nuclear arsenal you want to put more
weapons into the into the region very
important to
to remember
the trajectory of this we included
russia in western institutions council
of europe
uh we proposed to russia association
agreement with the eu i understand
and this is the way to make it return to
rules by putting more weapons into your
area well there aren't any now
the point is that when
uh nato was enlarging um there were
there were discussions with russia and
there was agreement not to put
substantia but you're putting twenty
percent when i finished my sentence yeah
please support substantial combat forces
on the territory of new members and the
substantial combat forces where there
was a discussion what that means and it
was generally agreed that two heavy
brigades would be within the threshold
and for the next 15 years no troops were
put in and we were all relatively happy
with the fact that we don't need i
understand but i'd like to stay with the
president if we may because you have
asked for more troops yes we want
pre-positioning of equipment we want
standing defense plans we want bigger
response forces
which raises the temperature we have
contingency plans but the danger i'm
just coming to the question the danger
is that we start talking to each other
in terms of weapons
yes and that's and that's already
happening unfortunately and it's already
unfortunately russia which started uh
being aggressive has started that logic
and we regret that very much but my
question is why do you need to do it
when you have article 5 of the nato i
finish the sentence because you have
pre-positioned troops and you have bases
whether in germany or in britain or in
spain or in italy or in turkey
and there are no threats to those
countries from a nation-state
and 15 years after central europe
joined
we are reluctantly
starting to do what was done
for west europeans many decades ago all
right do you trust article five and nato
look i'm a former defense minister i
trust where i see capabilities to
actually
fulfill that's not quite what i asked i
mean it's it's either a cast iron
guarantee or it's nothing yes but it has
to be backed up by physical capabilities
of fulfilling them so you don't believe
it comrade lenin used to say trust and
verify yeah but you don't believe it
then you don't believe it's a cast iron
guarantee well it's better recently
under president obama the contingency
plans were last at last written for the
new members and we now have rotating
presence and at last some exercises but
let me put it this way if poland was
invaded by russia do you believe
in your heart of hearts that america
would go to war for you
well i don't believe it's very likely
at all that poland will be invaded but
we know what should then happen yes nato
i'm asking you whether hand on heart you
believe that america would go to war to
protect poland i believe that the best
way to prevent such a war is true so you
don't you're not going to give me an
answer
i mean
late at night you're sitting there
thinking about all the thinkable wars
that could take place if you want to ask
about american intentions will they will
they protect you or not ask americans
what do you think because you are you
have to believe in it
you've had 15 years i believe that
deterrence is the best way to prevent
conflict
that weakness
encourages aggression i understand that
that's what my question deters mr koski
that was
i'm asking you whether you believe this
is a cast iron guarantee that you can
take to the bank in time of trouble can
you okay
i'm sure you've read article 5 of
washington treaty and it doesn't
actually
in the treaty oblige anybody to go to
war now it does say though that if an
attack on one nation
will be treated as an attack on all of
them and the likelihood of their force
to respond of the uh
joint action in my view is in proportion
to the physical ability to do so that's
why well america has huge physical
ability quite and it does that's why so
my question i come back to it is whether
you think it would use all means to
protect one of its nato members in this
instance poland for instance and you
seem to be very ambiguous on this no i
believe that countries are likely to
help
in times of trouble
in proportion to the amount they are
willing to exercise
when times are peaceful so we welcome
the recent
the first nato exercises in poland we
only had last year i understand
but the reason i keep pressing on this
point is that
last year you're pressing me on a
question that i can't answer because
you're well i'm questioning
other people's questions on whether you
have faith in those intentions that's
that's really what i'm asking the reason
i'm pressing is because
those secret recordings that caused such
a stir here recordings of your private
conversations that made their way into
the public arena seem to suggest that
you weren't that impressed with the
state of poland's alliance with america
in germany during the cold war the
germans needed reassurance that america
would really uh go to war for them
uh and they got it in the um
form of 300 000 u.s
at the height
u.s troops
um
permanently in germany until a couple of
years ago we had zero u.s but you were
quoted saying we will not we now have a
very small contingent so if you're
asking me
whether allies intentions
should be backed up by physical presence
and that that increases our faith in the
alliance yes it does because you were
quoted as saying the polish american
alliance is worthless even more harmful
actually because it gives poland a false
sense of security that these were
illegally made accordingly
the people who made them are being
prosecuted
and the transcript was manipulated i
understand but but does that reflect
your real view
my real view is that the more exercises
there are and the more presence there is
the more reassured polish public will be
but you somehow felt that poland wasn't
getting enough out of the relationship
to paraphrase that that you were doing
it wasn't you are doing all the giving
it wasn't you as i told you and those
conversations were accurate to that they
have been they have for the we've been
members of nato for 15 years until two
years ago there were nato bases in
britain in germany in spain in italy in
turkey but not in central europe where
it now turns out so you feel that
actually they are actually needed
poland is
threatened by violence to our east
britain is not threatened you have
american bases we don't what what do you
think before i just leave this question
of those illegal discussions what what
should the public take away from
this these kinds of revelations that
their politicians are prepared to be
much more firm in private than they are
in public the
there are two sides there are two sides
they're politicians there's the front oh
and
there's the real
person inside from wikileaks
and is the sounding off after a hard
thing on the wikileaks revelations we
also learned that poland has been and i
personally have been making this
argument the one i've just made to you
to the alliance to reassure us to put
more more capabilities here for years
and what i'm glad about is that
it at last has started
so today i am more satisfied than i was
but i understand i'm just talking about
the the gap between what you are
supposed to have said in those
conversations and what you say to me now
things changed two years ago we didn't
have any american presence people have
said that the the casualty is truth here
look the the public can i convey to you
the view of the minister's view that the
opinion change that two years ago we
were very disappointed
the russian aggression against ukraine
had already started and we still didn't
have any american or nato activity and
you're less disappointed today we have
nato activities you're less disappointed
things have improved but you okay still
don't think of article five as a cast
iron guarantee and when uh when push
comes to shove the nato atlantic council
will meet and will take decisions we
hope it will take the right this is why
late at night you're worried about what
america
really is going to do when the chips are
down you simply don't know do you well
we
we hope the allies will do what's right
it's just a hope i i
ask about this i'm talking about the u.s
because i wonder if you're satisfied if
we go back to the often denied story of
the secret cia villa the so-called black
site in the northeast of your country
the site where in 2002 2003 al-qaeda
suspects were brought and tortured
one of them was actually waterboarded
183 times there
in 2008
you were very careful in your denials
you told polish radio zet i can say that
from what i know about the time when i
was responsible for military
installations that there were no secret
prisons in poland where muslim
terrorists were supposedly in terrible
military
but
the rumors and the investigations have
been going on the european parliament
investigated two years before that 2006.
when you gave those denials
did you did you ditch were accurate
to the letter yes but you knew that this
had been going on didn't you
there are things that i uh that i'm
still bound by the polish official
official secret sector i i i understand
but but you had inquired when the rumors
presumably first i told the truth as
usual you you told the truth you
you stayed with the letter of the truth
but maybe not the spirit
but not the spirit perhaps because you
knew because you knew that this had been
going on what's your opinion
the fact was that polish intelligence
knew very well
what was going on didn't they and they
were paid to turn a blind eye we don't
apologize for intelligence collaboration
with the united states and other
countries this isn't a bad intelligence
collaboration this is bad
torture isn't it it's about torture uh
britain does all kinds of things with
the with the united states
we'll talk to the british about that but
i'm talking to you as a former minister
here this was about covering up torture
wasn't it
well polish uh personnel was not
involved in any such activity but polish
personnel turned a blind eye didn't they
and when they objected they were paid
substantial sums of money so that their
conscience
didn't worry them anyway look we were
together
in the fight against terrorism
in iraq poland was in charge of an
international division with
26 nations participating poland and
britain
were side by side in afghanistan and we
collaborate on intelligence gathering to
protect our citizens from
muslim fanatics but the u.s senate
report on cia interrogations said last
year poland threatened to halt the
transfer of al-qaeda suspects to a
secret cia jail on its soil but became
more flexible after the central
intelligence agency gave it a lot of
money
i've told you already what i can say we
do not apologize for
working together with our allies to
prevent our citizens from being harmed
by terrorists
and you don't apologize for breaking the
law
because you had signed the convention we
are actually the only country you had
signed the convention in europe
which has had a thorough investigation
of this incident
it's a third investigation it's taken
and it's still
it's been seven years and you were
wrapped over the knuckles by the
european court of human rights for
taking so long and i and i believe we've
paid out some compensation you have paid
out some compensation i hope uh but it
shouldn't it should never have happened
germany and the united states are as
law-abiding as poland is and by the way
i hope so i also hope that um our allies
in future keep their secrets rather
better
so you're not worried that torture was
carried out knowingly on your territory
you're much more worried that it leaked
the information
about
seriously bad people
plotting all the time including right
now to kill our citizens and you're not
worrying about violating the u.n
convention against torture which you
ratified in 1989. well as you've
admitted poland has actually paid out
compensation for this i hope other
countries do the same until this
investigation is complete and maybe
after seven years it's never going to be
complete
adam bodner professor of law at warsaw
university said the people who
authorized this betrayed the polish
constitution for money as long as poland
refuses to clarify the issue it will be
a problem for our image as a democracy
adam bodnar has just been elected
by parliament in which i said to be
poland's ombudsman for human rights
and uh you are asking me about the
actions of previous governments from
from over 10 years ago
no government i participated in did any
of these things i i'm puzzled because
under communism you became a dissident
because of things like this because of
torture
because of cover-up
and aren't you now trying to justify the
very things that you condemned
before do you want to talk about
northern ireland and about uh i would
with the british authorities and about i
would with the british authorities but
i'm talking to you about what happened
in poland yeah but uh um does that
excuse it because it goes on elsewhere
talk to the americans about it they did
it the polls had a conscience and were
paid to take their conscience for a walk
around the block we help our allies
even when it's illegal
even when um
they needed it particularly after 9 11.
yes
i'd like to talk a bit about europe for
a little while and your frequently
expressed desire
for greater integration greater unity
how's that looking after the last few
months of sharp bitter divisions within
the eurozone
how's that quest for unity well it's a
it's a big challenge uh and um
that's a very diplomatic and it's
challenging sure no but it's a disaster
isn't it
which
it's a it's a fiasco i agree which
originated in
countries of the eurozone starting with
the biggest ones
breaking the rules the growth and
stability pact you're talking about
germany and france germany and france
started breaking the rules smaller
countries took advantage of
this atmosphere of
of living off
very cheap interest rates and
misspending the money
and we i also believe we mismanaged the
uh the crisis itself
um but it was another mismanagement
wasn't it it was um i mean you asked
germany to lead in 2011 you left on
fixing the eurozone
you got domination instead of leadership
didn't you no what we
still have is reluctance of in this case
greece uh
uh to carry out very basic reforms let
me give you but you had them forced into
a deal that their government rejected
that the people specifically rejected in
a referendum in order to avoid complete
collapse of their currency but what has
that got to do with democracy within the
eurozone it makes a mockery of it
doesn't it well we can have that
argument that's a long and complicated
argument i'm which i'm happy to have
with you but the point you agree with me
the make some more of democracy no i
don't uh
the strong pushing the week around if
you take if you took out a mortgage on
your house
and then declared to your bank that
actually i've taken a vote in my family
and we're not going to pay back the
mortgage
um
because
it's not quite the same thing because
eurozone is about political integration
but it means that you have to you still
means you have to obey the rules and pay
back pay back the money because you have
to make money
the big countries don't obey the rules
no you have to make your economy
competitive look so
only the weak countries are supposed to
obey the rules aren't there no that's
what germany is doing
made a very painful adjustment it's
growing again ireland made a painful
adjustment it's growing again portugal
made a painful adjustment it's growing
again greece was beginning to grow again
and that's why it's so tragic and had
had a deal forced it on it that nobody
believes will work
nobody believes you you have to start
carrying out reforms the kinds of
reforms that we carry out here 25 years
ago so your integration is in tatters
poland and greece have about the same
number of civil servants but greece has
a quarter of our population
in poland we we devote eleven percent if
i remember it serves two pensions in
greece 18
greece cannot afford the size of public
sector it has and it has to make an
adjustment and can the euro zone which
you you think the collapse of the
eurozone you said this would be a
disaster i still have poland should join
the eurozone all we have seen all we
have seen is sharp divisions
uh stand-up browse
lack of leadership
and domination by by germany which you
have which you said
radical left radical right government
doesn't recognize that you have to live
within your means and for that they
could be shown the door but nobody
expected them to live within their means
actually they've now agreed to a deal
that is worse than it was first on offer
but they didn't have a choice did they
they were in a burning building with no
exits as one british politician wanted
to be in the eurozone you have to obey
the rules that's why in poland we are
preparing our economy very deliberately
uh and making ourselves competitive so
that when we join a uh reformed eurozone
both the eurozone and poland and your
benefit you're going to delay it as long
as possible well because this is as you
said this is a fiasco what's been going
on we had a national consensus to join
the eurozone in 2013 and if it hadn't
been for the crisis we would already be
members the eurozone needs to fix it fix
the fiasco yes
could i ask about you you
stood down after the scandal that we
alluded to with the illegal recordings
of your conversations did you need to
stand down
i did it because uh an election is
coming and uh
and we wanted as the civic platform we
wanted that issue of the political
agenda
and i hope it helps the party win the
election you told one media outlet
tongue-in-cheek you were thinking of
becoming a carpenter
yes with a colleague you've trimmed your
expectations in life somewhere in fact
i'm i'm writing a book about my seven
years at the foreign ministry thinking
of another one are we going to see you
back in public life if war is as
thinkable and there's so many dark
clouds on the horizon as you have said
oh here i am talking to you that's being
in public life i guess it is but are we
going to see you go you were tipped at
once for top positions in europe would
you
you still have ambitions in the
direction
well
you're not a man who simply gives up one
day and walks away right you're very
much interested and engaged in foreign
policy yes
and you're going to stay engaged and you
you're going to go after specific jobs
in future no i'm after 14 years in
government
more than half of independent poland
i need to
take stock
you need to take stock in a very
dangerous situation as far as you're
concerned with your country in a very
dangerous situation that's why we are
running we are hoping for a third term
for civic platform which has given
poland uh stability and economic success
and i feel has raised poland's standing
in
in europe brandon sikorsky thanks very
much for being thank you alexa thank you
you